thank you
[Music]
an Ohio animal shelter will name a
litter box after your ex
the little oh
[__]
oh my God it's like when they name a
cockroach and then they feed the
Cockroach to like a lizard dude people
are just so in Hamilton Ohio they have a
unique fundraiser as a lead up to
Valentine's Day they're saying they will
name a cat litter box after an
ex-romantic partner the gesture will
cost five dollars per box while the
promotion will run until February the
12th doesn't doesn't that count as
bullying yeah that's cyber bullying is
that is that considered bullying so it's
[__] up yeah I think so I think it is
that's what I was trying to say not like
in my personal definition but societies
I do what's the society's definition of
bullying that you're you're victimizing
someone that isn't proven to be guilty
of anything
yeah maybe that person was like maybe
yeah maybe they're the [__] how are
they like because they get robbed after
the kitty liters
like what's the bowling part because
then everyone goes ah look at look at
the years
just to generalize a little bit I think
that
cat people
are more likely to have like a big time
Grudge
and they're pretty lonely aren't you a
cat people yeah
[Laughter]
I think I know the intricacies enough to
know that like yeah they're [__]
lonely I've got [__] going on they're
fueled by pettiness yeah and then
they're like I'm gonna volunteer at my
local shelter and then those are the
people who are more likely to name it
after ex because it's like I got down
the Wayward path of being a [__] cat
person thanks to your ass yeah and so
now I'm gonna blame it all on you and
let the cats [__] and piss on it but
then you have to clean it up so who wins
is it recorded
and then to be like that's Catherine I
mean I guess it's just the opposite of
naming a star after somebody oh yeah
direct antithesis to that well but a
star is so like magical and the litter
box is so like um
inanimate but not a story but not that's
why it's it's the polar but what if
you're a star that's cooking some
beautiful world
that's true like a [__] star I mean no
no you're cooking it okay
wait what's that wait what's a cook
stock
I forgot how many documentaries you've
been watching
Neil deGrasse Tyson explaining cook
Stars dude
it starts off as a cook Nova then it
gets bigger it's got no stars yeah he
does but even like naming a star like
what a [__] racket that is like the
genius that came up with it but isn't it
you don't like it but doesn't that it's
a cash grab for sure doesn't NASA
recognize those stars do they oh wait no
they don't they don't huh what a [__]
cash crap [__] are people talking about
they're nuts have you guys ever hated
the X so bad that you wanted to do
something really bad but then you're not
like hardcore so you do something like
this yeah but I did it in Minecraft
wait what did you do with Minecraft
like you built an altar of her and
[__] care
what was the question
would you do in Minecraft to you know to
your exes I just like built her house
exactly how it used to be and then and
then I brought I invited monsters inside
of it and then I filled it with lava you
wanna know the meanest thing I did Tunex
that was like oh [__]
psychopath okay so like um I forgot what
happened but something happened with my
ex where she had a pretty bad strike and
I was like all right it's cool like
we'll just like strike towards you like
well no she did something wrong I forgot
what it was she did something wrong that
was clearly her fault she was
apologizing yeah I was like it's cool
you know just uh just know that if
anything like this happens again
um
I'm not gonna be upset matter of fact
it'll everything will seem like it's
perfectly fine could be for years
but somewhere down the line when
everything's at its best I will just be
gone oh [__]
and I said there's not gonna be a fight
there's not gonna be a disagreement of
any type you're just gonna be at Cloud
Nine and the next day I'll just be out
of your life holy [__] and as you do it
for somebody that's the same thing no I
said hey wait what did she say when she
heard that crying why did you why did
you do such a threat because I wanted to
mentally tear it because I was an idiot
I wanted a mentally Terrorizer mentally
terrorize her to be like all right you
want don't make this mistake again or
else this and that was the worst thing I
could think of which is terrible that's
really good I told my Aunt I was like
hey if we ever break up just so you know
and I'm not trying to threaten you at
all like that's what kind of was I'll
kill you
[__] kill you [__] I'll kill you and
I'll kill your family no I said I'll
kill you it's a little lighter than that
I no I was like I was like I will just
disappear from your life like I just
can't deal with like knowing you being
your friend no Dramatics yeah yeah I
just disappeared and then I I actually
did that and I think she was pretty
shocked the way of Brian oh you actually
did it yeah when we broke up I did it
the way you set it up though it sounds
like the next scene is her in a straight
jacket like I love him I love him yeah
a good like crazy mental one and that's
like I think a lot of like luckily I
outgrew that type of [__] but yeah
that's kind of like if I'm giving advice
to like like dudes I'm like yeah don't
do [__] like that sometimes when you
when like you just want to hurt someone
back when they do something to you it's
like I was really creative at thinking
of the worst things what was this strike
like whatever a guy homies give her a
ride home or something it clearly it had
to be it had to be something that no
that's a big thing it had to be
something that's stupid it had to be
something that stupid that was like too
immature to like look past something's
dumb because it was like what it's like
he's like
you do that again
yeah yeah on the phone and take it oh
good luck that was kind of scary bro
this set of skills yeah to leave you I'm
Cloud Nine and that's the thing it's
like because I'm not physically violent
but I like I'm very like mind game like
at the time I thought that was the worst
thing you do if someone is do a mind
game yeah so then I was like oh I'm not
I'm never gonna shock you in the face or
in like stupid like that but I will do
this I'll suck it in your brain yeah
smooth brain and it's so like messed up
that's why I'm like no I don't don't
play that role
don't do it yeah so if you had if if you
had the option of doing this is this
something that appeals to you guys a x
that I hate a litter box name I don't
hate anymore no I would just do what
Ryan did back in the day I think that's
a much no way dude it's pretty like I
feel like we all walked into this pet
store that's doing a fundraiser clearly
it'll be more funny for us to all just
buy one and name each other in yeah and
it's like you know
funnier man because then I'll enjoy it
but if it's like like if I'm so petty
that I put my ex's name on it I'm not
gonna be like
you're a slanter you're the [__] right
well yeah because nothing's more uncool
than admitting you still think about it
exactly yeah like they have rent in your
head dude you're obsessed right like
you're losing then yeah you know or you
just get a litter box that says the
careful boys and we put in Anthony's
house so your cat just [__] shits all
over and stuff it's just all over the
camera yeah just every smart by the way
and as bad as it was like as bad as the
relationship was and let's say like you
you're not like even if it left on bad
terms right
you get to a point where it doesn't even
affect you anymore like you don't think
back in that way you don't even
wish ill upon them you're just like well
well that was a moment in life and I
learned from it but I don't I don't feel
like you're going back and being like
nah I want to get them back for the way
that they hurt me or I don't know like
how do you guys feel about naming the
cat litter Canada or something yeah or
France yeah that's pretty strong yeah
Atlanta international airports now
that's a rivalry I could get behind
Steve's gonna get a litter box and name
it [__] American Airlines
any chance you get to dunk on [__]
American Airlines borrow you got your
your flight canceled he's like I bet it
was like it was [__] American man
[__] them I think that's something they
lost my luggage worst thing about them
I'll never forget this this is like nine
days ago it was like no this cat he's
like um I was like I was like
I was like wait the the terminals right
here you guys have the jetway right here
yeah right there I can't get on the
plane no sir sorry we closed the cabin
door that's what happened to us and I'm
like I it's all right there you won't
let me know no sorry sir next flight is
it seven in the morning and I was like
cool it's uh it's seven at night right
now so that's awesome did you sleep at
the airport I slept at the airport I'm
like what did you just pull up a chance
yeah and Nikki's like go get out down I
was like no [__] these people I'm not
giving them dime
[Laughter]
where by the way they play Creepy
[__] music all night long oh to [__]
with you yeah to make sure you don't
sleep like what's a creepy you know what
I'm so cheap I slept so and you've dealt
with the night terrors
comfortable spot what did you do
terminal it I don't know I but I'm six
foot four what do you want me to do I
didn't find a comfortable spot on the
floor yeah it's impossible to just find
out because they're still playing Taylor
Swift all night you got any other
stories that accentuate how tall you are
I'm gonna stop bragging yeah so so um I
was hanging out with a fully grown adult
male right
but then I thought he's just a little
baby
[Laughter]
[Music]